another interesting story legal Story
related to the failed former president
that I briefly want to talk about
um a judge has ruled that Donald Trump
indeed must give evidence in this
um a defamation lawsuit related to
alleged rape by Donald Trump the hill
reports a federal judge has denied
former president Trump's motion to pause
the proceedings of a defamation suit
against him from a woman who has accused
him of rape while appeals over the case
play out setting him up for a deposition
next week this is I know Trump was
recently deposed by Leticia James
this is another deposition in another
case now as a reminder this is not a
criminal rape case this is a lawsuit for
defamation related to the things Donald
Trump said about a rape accuser
e Gene Carroll U.S District Judge writes
the hill Lewis Kaplan ruled yesterday
that Trump's argument didn't meet the
legal threshold required for a stay to
be issued Trump has been pushing for the
U.S to be substituted in Eugene
Carroll's lawsuit against him because
the comments Trump made denying her
claim and criticizing her happened when
he was president Trump's argument is I
shouldn't be the defendant in this
lawsuit for the things I said about
Eugene Carroll including if I recall
correctly that she's not really his type
as if that's a reason rather than saying
I don't rape people he said she's not my
type
doesn't make sense that I would have
raped her insane
he says he was president at the time and
thus really the federal government
should be the defendant rather than him
um the hill notes the details of the the
case here Carol accused Trump of raping
her at a Manhattan department store in
the 90s Trump has countered by accusing
Carol of lying and making remarks
criticizing her appearance yeah
Trump requested that proceedings in the
defamation case that Carol filed be
paused while the D.C court of appeals
weighs whether Trump was acting in His
official capacity when I said she was
too ugly to rape I was functioning in an
official capacity so the federal
government should be the defendant
that's where we are in 2022 at this
point in time Kaplan wrote in his ruling
the court could rule either way on the
question but Trump gave no reason for
him to conclude that the ruling would be
in his favor he also found that Trump
failed to show a meaningful meaningful
threat of irreparable injury if a stay
is not put in place
uh listen you can't sue me for
defamation because I was acting in my
official capacity as president at that
time now what do we expect he will do
if indeed he is deposed probably plead
the Fifth at his last deposition with
Leticia James Trump pled the fifth about
400 times Trump previously has said only
the mob pleads the fifth you don't plead
the fifth if you're innocent his own
experience with the deposition changed
his mind on that surprisingly the
important thing to remember is that as a
defendant in a civil suit pleading the
fifth may not be as useful to him as it
can be in a criminal case I heard from a
criminal defense attorney who said you
know
in this is a criminal defense attorney
who wrote to me and said David Sir With
Tears in his eyes he said David sir when
I defend people criminally
juries are given instructions that the
lack of testimony from my client or
pleading the fifth cannot be used to
draw negative inferences or to point
towards guilt you can't hold against
them that they don't testify or that
they pled the fifth in a civil lawsuit
Trump or whoever pleading the fifth or
refusing to answer questions can be used
to draw a negative inference and
theoretically as part of a guilty
verdict we're thinking many steps ahead
but an important difference in terms of
civil versus criminal now I know many of
you are wondering what about the
criminal aspect of this
um
to be honest I don't know where that
stands I know that there are questions
as the statute of limitations this
alleged event happened during the 90s
and a number of other obstacles but what
we're dealing with right now is a civil
suit for defamation wherein I'm sort of
breaking this down to its its kernel of
Truth
Trump sort of said e Gene Carroll is not
attractive enough for me to actually
have raped she's not my type which is a
crazy thing to say uh we'll have more on
this and Other Stories from today on our
Instagram you can find that at
davidpackman show and we will be right
back after this short break one of our
sponsors is paired the app for couples
every day paired gives you and your
partner questions quizzes games to have
fun to stay connected to deepen your
conversations and get to know each other
better what's great about it is you
don't even have to be in the same room
especially with the baby right now my
girlfriend and I are quite busy and
paired really helped us to stay
connected you get a daily question to
answer you can't see your partner's
answer until you answer yourself and
their questions about everything
relationship life intimacy other things
and all of the exercises were developed
by academic psychologists and expert
relationship therapists as well
questions like what what makes you feel
lucky in your relationship great when
you want to remember and have gratitude
a really great thing what's an activity
you could try together this month
actually gets people thinking about
things to do it can go in really funny
directions as well but it just always
feels like time well spent go to
paired.com Pacman to download the app
and get a seven day free trial the link
is down below